[Music]
please don't get involved
yeah what's up fam
hope you guys had a great july 4th it is
july 5th tuesday use this show shot on a
monday
but the thick boy staff had monday off
they want the holidays off
so that's how we got to do it around
here
if you want to talk to hr you're looking
at them what's up complain to me
um yeah nothing nothing like a little
break although not too much of a break
because i the squad did work saturday
night we had uh ufc 2
uh 76 calabasas fight companion so
that's a bit of a take on for the squad
we're basically working uh what from
five to eleven five to midnight around
there around there the squad's doing
work
um if you haven't watched yet it's a fun
one it's a fun one ufc 276 fight
companions available right now on thick
boy we had josh thompson
uh
luke rockhold i almost said luke thomas
luke rockhold
and my boy trevor wallace trevor is
absolutely hilarious one of my favorite
people on the planet we do a lot of uh
we do a lot of uh you know
[Music]
staying up together all over la so
that's fun um
yeah man it was a grand old time it was
a grand old time uh those fight commands
they're fun they're funny when the
fights are saucy the fights i i wouldn't
describe ufc 276 as saucy it you know
it was a great card on paper
but um the the prelims were fun the
prelims there's definitely some mvps on
the prelims ian gary if this kid's not
on your radar you [ __ ] up in gary is
a complete savage
technical savage big for a welterweight
technically he is just
checks all boxes kids checks all the
goddamn boxes
he put on a clinic against gabriel green
um
you know and then it's tough because yet
the ufc is in good hands because you got
a lot of uh young talent who is coming
up and they're coming up fast so you
know just on these prelims uh on the abc
portion you had ian gary and uh jalen
turner jalen turner if you're not
familiar with him at lightweight he's
huge i think he's six two or six three
he's huge for a lightweight and this kid
has all the hype on him there's a reason
he was the main event on the abc card uh
they gave him his toughest opponent yet
and brad riddell you know brad got
knocked out by fazeev who's fighting
this weekend um so brad's following some
tough times it took jaylen turner 45
seconds
and submission really isn't his game
either kid's up he's going to be a
problem big big problem i would assume
he jumped in the top 15 in the
lightweight uh rankings there probably
you know somewhere between 13 to 15. but
he definitely earned his ticket there
ian gary i'm telling this kid's so fun
to watch man he's so fun to watch
um he's a good one and then when it
comes to the main card
which is what we cover on the cowboys
fight companion
with the boys i was so excited for pedro
munoz sean o'malley like the rest of you
and then you know you get an eye poke uh
definitely accidental i don't think it
was a case of you know and if you look
at the eye poke it was like a palm like
glove it wasn't like a jon jones poke
you know what i'm saying where he's
putting his hands out it's kind of it's
like a palm and he's like backing away
it's just such a
it's just unfortunate you know
and um
a lot of people like go munos wanted out
of the fight you know how stupid you
gotta be to say that
oh munoz knew he was losing he went out
of the fight well first of all i think
two other three judges gave him the
first round and there wasn't like
anything crazy going on where you know
pedro amino was thinking himself oh my
god this sean o'malley's gonna knock me
out you know there's none of that
it's just unfortunate and i'm a guy i
don't know how you guys feel about it
but when a fight is a no contest there's
my poke it gets cancelled i'm good i
don't wanna see it again
i think a lot of people like oh just
reschedule it there's something i don't
know what it is i can't explain to you
why i feel like that
i'm good it's like this let down and i
just the hype's over with between them
it was a perfect fight for sean o'malley
to you know fight the toughest opponent
yet perfect style match up for him and
then this happens so it's kind of like
now we move on and i think that's uh
that's actually a problem for sugar
shawn because if the ufc does go all
right you don't want to redo that he
wants to give you someone else in the
top 10. you know it's gonna be in he
didn't get a taste of those those
upper echelon guys he didn't get a taste
and
if you are a sugar shawn hater which i'm
not i [ __ ] love that dude and i do
think he has all taunt in the world to
be champion and i do think he can beat a
lot of those top 10 guys he just has to
prove it to the haters out there
but if you are a hater of sugar shawn
you're going well he lost the first
round and then you're gonna watch just
the you know obviously ufc's invested in
sugar shawn he has a new contract he's
definitely one of the most famous guys
besides is he
probably the most famous guy on the card
you could argue vocal knives max
hallway's pretty big too
sugar sean that's what's crazy sugar
sean
hasn't fought any of these top dudes and
we're arguing right now is he the most
famous guy besides izzy on the card
there's alexander volkonovsky max
hallway sugar shawn
izzy's at the top there it's tough he's
up there that's also a card with jim
miller and cowboy cerrone who have the
most fights ever i think jim miller has
40 [ __ ] fights
uh sean o'malley has what five you know
what i'm saying that's how the kids made
some waves in a short amount of time so
it's it's it
it's not good that that happened as a no
contest um and for those of you going oh
pedro wanted out you don't know pedro
munoz you idiots he is a absolute
stand-up dude uh and a savage savage
have savage he wouldn't not not a chance
and reed harris uh
even uh tweeted out that the
the next morning on sunday morning he
saw uh muno's eyes and it was completely
shut and swollen so
i mean come on come on
uh go up wood sugar sean tweet the only
thing is that this word and again i get
what sugar shawn's doing first man to
finish paige there you go this is his
thing this is schtick right it's not
that i agree with it but it's just it's
his mo so first man to finish pedro
breaking news sugar stay athletic
commissioner officially rules page over
sugar a fat [ __ ] dumb dub w for sugar
he's gonna double down you know because
he doesn't want the hype to stop and
this gets him in the narrative and we're
talking about him after this big ufc
276. because really you look at ufc 276
who are we talking about talking about
pierre right with the knockout of sugar
of strickland
um
you're talking about volkanovsky who had
a flawless performance against max
holloway
and then you're talking about uh sugar
shawn even though it was a no contest
or you're talking in izzy and for the
majority of the media outlets out there
in mma they're talking about is in a
negative light which you're not gonna
get here i think that's absolutely
ridiculous and uncalled for
um
so i think for sugar shawn doubling down
going yeah i beat him
i know you guys hate it it's his mo
though same thing with cheeto vera he
said i've never lost like well
technically yeah you know and then oh
this is win well technically he doesn't
live in that world and his fan base
which is pretty massive he's like yeah
you won that one
do you man
do you baby
is the only thing you know if you go the
go the bantamweight rankings for me chin
because if trigger sean his first real
test is a no contest
he's 13.
munoz is at nine
donald cruz has a match up uh i like rob
font for him
if you want to go up to seven like rob
font for him and then after that you
know it's off to the races then you're
messing with the big boys you're messing
with the biggest boys not that the guys
you know 12 through
9 aren't big boys i'm just saying you're
after the races there um
i know sugar shawn uh wants to be in
those top guys and getting paid like it
i i'd like a sugar shot o'malley jack
shore fight to be honest oh i thought
you don't yeah our boy jack shorts a
little taste of the rainbow daddy
remember uh in yearbooks when kids would
put uh life what was it life's a rainbow
taste it
do you write did they sign your
yearbooks like that it was like a thing
at my school it was like life life's a
rainbow taste some skittles reference i
forget i was like all right dude well
whoever originally wrote this is
fantastic but the rest of you copy it it
makes no sense you know
um
yeah so so for suga it's
it's not ideal you know this is his
first big test and it ends in a no
contest and he said it's a win the fc is
going to promote it you know as moving
on
i don't know i can't explain it to you
guys i don't know what it is once a
fight falls out like
though i'd say the only fight that fell
out where i was like okay we have to
make this happen was tony ferguson his
prime and could be that was the only one
where they could reschedule that bad
[ __ ] ten times a week come on daddy
here we go buying the pay-per-view just
for that and it always fell out you know
that's the only fight i always wanted to
see even if they reschedule it outside
that once this stuff happens i'm out
let's move on
let's move on daddy um
i really think they messed up by putting
pedro and sugar shawn first i think
that's why there was a no contest i
think they should have kicked the
pay-per-view off to get our dicks hard
with brian barbarina and robbie lawler
and clearly i told you guys if that
thing goes all three rounds fight the
night but but the chance that happens
not good somebody's gonna get stopped uh
i did have uh brian barbarina in my
draftkings parlay he was one of the
three men on there sean o'malley was
also on there so i think that messes up
the parlay and then i had izzy
so you know
brian i'm i'm two out of three and with
a no contest not too bad
uh brian barbarian was the only
slight dog there he was minus 105.
robbie lawler's minus 115 so you know
it's not like i'm
taking crazy chances here
um
that but by far the most entertaining
fight was barbarina robbie lawler that
was so goddamn fun if you're robbie
lawler what do you do you're 40 you know
clearly can still compete
um
you know when people go rob robbie needs
to wrestle robin needs to shoot oh
really
that's like telling the cheetah not to
run fast it's literally what he does
dude that's his it's in his dna he can't
fight any other way i do think there's
entertaining fights at welterweight
forum all day
all day now do i want to see it ian gary
robbie lawler wouldn't be mad at it is
that throwing robbie lawler to the young
dublin
wolverine yeah it is but i'm here for it
and gary i'm telling you folks
you need to check that box
as a fan favorite you check him and
arnold allen
i think on the companion we're talking
about who could
give birkanovsky the most fits and
arnold allen is my number one guy and we
will get to that uh but if you go back
chin um so you have brian barbarina and
uh robbie lawler saved the day because
that pedro munoz sugar shawn fight broke
our hearts it was just uneventful
especially listen when you're on a fight
campaign i got three hours on the air
you need some entertainment man you know
i can only talk so much so it came to a
screeching halt with pedro he knows sean
o'malley and then brian barbarina said
hold my mohawk i got you boys did his
thing you got a great fight there and
then alex pierra and sean strickland
um this one was interesting right
because
a part of me is a little resentful
towards alex pierre because he's only
had what three fights and then they're
literally just doing the easiest
match-ups to get them to izzy
i don't think we've ever seen this if
you think about other guys and alex
pierre has a background a world-class
background in kickboxing i mean world
champion and glory you know for light
heavyweight champion middleweight
chairman savage straight [ __ ] savage
on the feet um
yeah i mean he lost his last one i think
got overturned so i think he's currently
the light heavyweight champion there's
something weird there but either way he
was the middleweight champion and the
light heavyweight champion period that's
that guy's pedigree he's a freaking
savage he's also enormous that's the
other thing he's enormous so ufc loves
him um
but i have does anyone else feel like
this i have a bit of a problem where the
ufc is fast tracking him just to get to
eat izzy and give him the perfect
matchups in order to get there well i
don't think we've ever seen this
because if you look at it like who came
on the scene blew onto the scene brock
lesnar they didn't give him ideal
matchups off the bat he fought like a
heath herring who's a dog you know they
did not you get
another guy granted he has no background
in fighting but still you'll get cm punk
didn't do him any favors they thought
you know they could toss them a savage
dude
so
over time you you know you look at uh
james tony another guy
crazy boxing background they said here
is literally the best wrestler we have
on the roster sir couldn't be a worse
matchup for you his new ankle pick can
take you right down you could have gave
him a boxer if you want him to succeed
we it's with uh alex pierre he's just
getting spoon fed these guys to just to
get to izzy we've never seen anything
like it now here's the other thing to me
it's so short-sighted but also shows you
how dominant izzy is where there's
nothing else for him the ufc is like we
have to do something here man someone's
like all right let's get this alex
pierre kid in here who's beat him twice
back in the day and kickboxing only
there's a narrative there like yeah but
how are we gonna get him there just give
him the easiest fights possible the
perfect matchups
you know so it shows you how dominant
izzy is which i think should be the
takeaway of all this uh chatter right
now online
um because is he's so dominant they had
to fast-track and alex pierra with three
fights they give him a top four guy in
sean strickland who's the perfect
matchup for him
you know he just starches him
um i did pick sean strickland to win
that fight because i
thought sean strickland would use his
fight iq
and wrestle early on and then as the
fight got going would uh capitalize on
the feet once pierre was more tired that
was not the case that was not the case
and if you did bet on sean strickland
you're not happy this morning you
probably uh lost the money by your kids
firecrackers because sean strickland
went i'm just as good as he is at
striking and then pierre went i don't
think so check this left hook out and
then knocked him unconscious so that's
cool but with sean strickland um
michael bisping said this and i i've
heard this and i'm always
hesitant to criticize guys if i'm not
there if i don't know if i didn't train
with him personally if i haven't seen
them i'm always i i hesitate to
criticize a guy but bisming uh was
saying on his uh bt sport show which is
one of my favorite shows he does a great
job on that he was saying uh
you know
pierre was going to win because he goes
sean strickland has no wrestling because
he can't wrestle
but
remember we had marvin vittorio on food
truck and he also did the the hot takes
the shop show hot takes breaking down
these fights
he also thought sean strickland was
gonna win and he's trained with him but
he was saying sean strickland's
wrestling has gotten better because he
trained with that bellator
world champion who just beat mousasi
he's saying that kid's a wrestler he's
going with him his wrestling's getting
better so i figured there's
the possibility of
improving his grappling especially you
don't need to be you know freaking
uh first-team all-american uh ncaa
wrestler to take alex pierre down anyone
with decent jiu jitsu takedowns should
be able to take this kickboxer down
pretty easily
so i figured sean street gonna do some
more of that wear him out and then if he
wanted to you know play that game that
dicey game on the feet he'd do it later
in the rounds but he just was like nah
just jab with them and you know keep my
chin high and
leave some openings for him and for a
guy like alex pierre that i mean you're
just chumming the waters baby he was
chumming those brazilian waters and that
big great white
every bit of that alex pierre just ate
him alive man
so
fast tracked and now he's getting a
title shot against izzy
ah and you look at that to me like i was
saying before i won that long rant about
this the alex pierre
experiment to me is so short-sighted
so let's talk about it so alex pierre is
getting the next title shot right uh
there's a story line there
of course seeing what he did to sean
strickland the the
common fans excited now right like this
guy's a knockout beast very cool um he
beat izzy twice and kicked boxing
[ __ ] 10 years ago here we go this is
the one getting beat izzy sure
so let's say in this weird world we live
in he beats izzy which i don't think is
asking too much considering it's gonna
be a straight kickboxing match i do
think izzy is a better
mma striker he's more
fluent on the feet when it comes to four
ounce gloves he has more tools uh his
foot works a lot better
um
but let's say alex pierre were to beat
izzy okay so you have a guy who doesn't
speak english brazilian champion at
middleweight
okay
and then who else chan if you're the
middleweight rankings right now
i i i challenge you guys i [ __ ]
challenge you guys
in the top
i'll say seven because eight nine can't
wrestle
in the top seven
who does pierre beat
go
you're literally just fast tracking a
guy who doesn't speak english because he
beat izzy 10 years ago in kickboxing and
he's stylistically the worst matchup for
izzy on paper you're trying to dethrone
your biggest champion
for a guy who doesn't speak english who
the fans really don't know because he
beat him 10 years ago because your
champion has been so dominant we can't
figure out what else to do with them so
let me get straight you're gonna
fast-track a guy who again doesn't speak
english
can't wrestle
can't do jiu-jitsu isn't an mma fighter
just does kickboxing and if he beats him
he literally
can't beat anybody in the top seven
that's the plan
name one guy he beats in the top seven
chin besides sean strickland
go
let's go through it robert whittaker can
wrestle his ass off
wrestle his ass off was a monster in
australia wrestling jira cannon air
yee he's taking him down dude not the
best wrestler but can he's big can take
him down marv vittori taking him down
guarantee you
derek brunson the worst matchup in the
world for him the worst
paulo costa
not great he might be able to beat him
paul got you know you never know
jack hermansen
do you think he beats him [ __ ] no darren
tell your uh i'll give you kelvin gaslum
nope
nope
so what do you do
so let's say in this weird [ __ ] world
we live in he knocks out izzy
all right well you're gonna get two for
one there because it's been such a
dominant champion he's gonna have to do
the rematch then as he beats him there
right so that's one one then you do the
trilogy but again you're just investing
a guy who has no future in the ufc
unless you guys baby him like you've
done his entire ufc career and keep
giving them ideal matchups
so what are you just going to fast track
other perfect stylist match-ups for him
so let's say he beats izzy and they go
we don't do a rematch here's darren till
because he'll strike with him
the guy seven through one's like what
the [ __ ] damn tell him one in forever
they go yeah you're right man and they
beat santilla like all right what uh
here's uriah hall
he'll strike with him
okay
here's brad tavares but he just lost we
know it's gonna be a cool fight though
that's what we're doing now
there's if you look at the business plan
it makes no [ __ ] sense to me
and he's a very dangerous match of
frizzy super dangerous
anybody else he's [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] mark my words he will not be
around long i don't think so
depending on the as soon as he loses the
ufc is going to go cool now welcome to
the real world here's derek bronson
you just fought the champ we can't give
you a guy
rank below five you just lost to the
champ and you beat the number four guy
uh here's vittori here's cannon air
here's brunson here's hermonsen what are
you gonna do dude
he don't beat any of those guys
and this isn't me hey john pierre it's
just me telling you he has no grappling
or wrestling whatsoever also if you're
gonna bang a guy he ain't young
that's the other thing about him he's
not that young they have to fast track
him this isn't a sugar shawn or patty
pimlet you know uh prospect that we can
build up over time how old is he he
looks older than me
34. he's 34 at middleweight dude
heavyweight br even 34 heavyweight
two years
middleweight
with those savages
do we really think this is the smartest
plan ufc
again i know you guys had yesterday off
and you're in your iowa style actually
your marketing meeting today and like
real quick i just wanna i hope there's
one guy in there he's gonna get fired
every time we raise his hand goes dana i
get the alex pierre thing and that's
cool and that buildup's gonna be lit man
what uh what if he beats him
dang that's right right uh darren taylor
you think like what about the other guys
like yeah you're right all no
uh because if we give him anybody else
he loses
because well if he does be dizzy then we
had to do the rematch right and then do
the the rubber match and
so that's that just this guy who can't
beat anybody else but izzy is constantly
gonna fight for the title it's insane to
me it makes no sense
and to me this shows you how
dominant of a champion is he has been
now was that main event a bit of a
snoozefest yeah i'll give you that
my
my issue is not with izzy izzy's the
champ jerichoner wants what is he has
it's up to him to make the fight
now there are other champions who
show out put it on the line every time
sure but when you look at the reigning
champs you look at the reigning the guys
who constantly defend the title making
big boy money because the only way to
make big boy money in the ufc is become
multiple defending champion that's when
you get pay-per-view points that's when
the endorsements are coming whether it's
a head kick knockout or a five-round
boring decision it doesn't matter your
money's rolling in and izzy knows this
and izzy's legacy knows this so is he
goes all right
he has to bring the fight to me now if
they don't bring the fight you get a yo
romero fight you get you know these
decisions you get the jared cannon air
fights
it's on them and i'm i would assume
jared cannon is watching the tape this
morning going [ __ ] it was my one shot
it's my one shot i played it safe
because i didn't want to get the
highlight reel knockout i was playing it
safe i took ready
zero chances in 25 minutes against izzy
otasanya i took
zero [ __ ] chances to win that fight
i guess the feathering cap is i lasted
five rounds with the best middleweight
in the world of all time
yeah that's what you're going for he
took zero chances
look at the guys that take chance
against izzy look what happened to him
robert whitaker destroyed paulo casa
destroyed kelvin gassim
top three i'd say top two middleweight
fights of all time if you take a chance
against izzy you get a phenomenal fight
if you play it safe he's like this money
in the bank for me dude i'm in cruise
control i'm in the hov lane you suckers
got to get me out of this hov lane
i'm cruising man i'm making all the
money i'm getting all the endorsements
i'm on all the [ __ ] promotional stuff
you want to take this away from me you
want to take away my records my title
make me
to me i don't have a problem with is he
doing this
and i know uh what's the name pratt
[ __ ] the guy and chris chris pratt
was like for me uh i'm disappointed
because
uh you know if you talk all that [ __ ]
you gotta show out you gotta do
hey bro
we're not telling you how to make
[ __ ] what's it what movie is he in
jurassic park don't get me started on
jurassic park that thing we knew was a
nightmare what's the other thing he's on
um what is that what's the most famous
one he's guardians of guardians of
galaxy that's like izzy
criticizing guardians of the galaxy
going ah i think grew talks too much
probably like what the [ __ ] do you know
about movies this is like nothing at all
so he'd be like
hold on this is the first time you're on
a national broadcast for the ufc and you
take this opportunity to clown our boy
izzy
that's like me yeah he was on the ufc
post show clown and izzy going listen
i'm just an actor
so he knew he was going down that road
they always do that but i'm just an
actor but
izzy blah blah blah and i heard now
rogan swears by chris pratt says he's a
great guy i actually enjoy chris pratt i
like chris pratt he gets a lot of hate
online i don't get it but there's the
thing i'm not a fan
lackluster over deer cannon there
pitter patter performance all that talk
pitter patter
pitter pat no pitter patter is called
acting sir pitter patter would be acting
because none of it's real is it
you don't really have a best friend
that's a raccoon that talks to you do
you you don't have a tree stump named
gru that's basically vin diesel do you
that's pitter patter
is he putting his
freaking health on the line to fight
this monster and jared cannon air and
jared taking
zero shots that's his issue
not izzy's izzy makes the same money
dear candidate wants what izzy has and
didn't do anything to sacrifice to get
that so what are you gonna do
here's my hate on izzy you get the guy
from [ __ ] jurassic park hey don is he
the guy who's riding on a motorcycle run
away from t-rex's hate on izzy that's
what we do these days
pitter patter dude here's the thing
about those dinosaurs kids you know
t-rex can't run that fast right
did you know that you know they were
slow as [ __ ]
you know anybody in this room could
outrun a t-rex is why because they're
the size of the titanic they're slow as
[ __ ] they're not that scary you know in
the their main thing where they go
that's also fake they think they were
high pitched didn't yell that loud and
also covered in feathers
oh and those velociraptors that always
cause problems jurassic park you know
the size of a [ __ ] poodle
that's pitter patter dude how dare you
criticize izzy how
dare you love your movies i am a fan i
don't think you should get all the hate
you get i am a fan but you can't come to
the ufc for the first time get on the
mic and hate on our guy we can't have
that dude
we just simply can't have that do you
want me to give you a hot take on
jurassic park i'll tell you when i knew
it was [ __ ] when there's dinosaurs in
the city that's when i'm out if it's
around trees i'm in if you're around
buildings i'm out it's pretty simple
dude and pterodactyls would be a [ __ ]
nightmare in the city you want to make a
horror movie pterodactyl horror movie
i'm in on that that sounds cool
but these little dinosaurs run around
the city and i apparently in jurassic
park the new one it's like humans and
[ __ ] dinosaurs get along
i'm out dude
unless it's ice age wither cartoons i'm
not watching it
that's pitter patter sir that's what
that is how dare you come on our
broadcast that you are our ufc post
fight broadcast and the first thing on
your mouth is you hate on the main event
jesus you know what sir you won't be
invited
back unless joe rogan gives you tickets
daddy
but you probably will so you'll be back
but god he and all this hey dude and
then you hate on izzy
that is weird that of all people chris
pratt would say that it's so strange to
me now everyone has their opinion that
right twitter thinks they're geniuses
and instagram thinks they're geniuses
they want to criticize izzy
you guys don't realize
if izzy were to lose and take chance
against guy like jared cannonaire the
what the the ripple effect it has on his
legacy his career and also his bank
account and his family's bank account
so it's not up to him to risk it all
against guy like jared cannon air hears
him about ken air he will never be back
there so for him not to risk it is
insane to me
because if you're watching izzy's tape
you can see kind of moments where maybe
you take advantage of it but also you
realize if you don't take opportunities
you're gonna get out point he's more
technical than anybody including alex
pierre i hate to tell you guys alex
pierre i know we're on his nuts because
you beat sean strickland he ain't a
better mma striker than izzy he's not
and if you don't think izzy would head
kick [ __ ] sean strickland's head off
if he played that same game and jabbed
with him for a round you're out of your
goddamn mind easy could do that same
thing but all you guys are on ox
speeders nuts right now y'all must have
forgot
because izzy to get to where he's at now
was doing that against top tier
contenders who weren't perfect matchups
who were [ __ ] savages like kevin
kelvin gaslum like robert whittaker in
his [ __ ] prime even joe romero
you know what i'm saying so this hater
gets izzy i'm telling you you guys need
to stop that [ __ ]
and as he pointed out too this happened
with gsp
muhammad ali all the great champions
deal with this and y'all must have
forgot how short our memories are
because you're busy watching jurassic
park
t-rex in the [ __ ] city you're busy
with that dude y'all must have forgot
anderson silva had some snooze fest
but it wasn't anderson silva's fault it
was the guy who was fighting his fault
anderson silva had everything to lose
it's on the contender to bring the pain
dude take chances try to get the guy out
of there
and now because izzy's been so goddamn
good at that the ufc had to fast track a
guy who doesn't speak english who beat
him ten years ago can't beat anybody
else in the [ __ ] top seven in order
to find him a formal opponent that we're
excited about
way to go
way to go chris pratt
hope you're happy
i bet you'll be front row in that
[ __ ] alex pierre izzy fight with a
brazil flag just trying to win that
brazilian fan base
i don't know why you take i think as you
know kind of a trumper and he was
associated with that church
the church thing but even he came out i
was like i hadn't never been to that
church
[ __ ] but the thing is is even if he
did he shouldn't get hate who gives a
[ __ ]
that's what's next crazy
i think is the uh after this pierrot
fight you know i think for izzy
uh light heavyweights the move and him
invoking after you talked about it
leading up to this fight how they're
both gonna test the waters even izzy
tried it you know with yon but that was
just a nightmare of a matchup but now
with a guy like yuri who fancied himself
a striker that would be fun for izzy
that's a much better matchup he's not
gonna grapple trying to lay on top of
him he's gonna you know try and knock
him out which would be so exciting so i
think that's there for izzy
obviously if he gets past alex pierro
which i think he does
you guys just on this alex beer hype
train right now you almost forgot how
long has he's been doing it and i heard
the walkout he was like one of the best
wildcats of all time we didn't see it
did we guys
on the fight come on we gotta have some
with air piece in so we can't they can
be like oh it's the you know i don't
know what's going on
i don't know what he's doing you know
but i heard it was a fantastic walk i
heard even uh
the [ __ ] undertaker tweeted out
something like that was lit
i don't think he said lit because he's
60 but you get the idea
uh then the co-main event
volkanovsky just
you know proved i think he's the best
featherweight of all time you know josh
thompson wanted to argue that um jose
aldo is and of course
to me the goat
conversation changes it's pretty fluent
it just depends it's always fluent so
with volkanovsky you know when he came
on food truck i said you know for me as
such a max hallway fan
and it's so hot in here again so that's
cool but for volkanovsky is such a
max hallway fan i need that
trilogy fight and i need you to beat him
convince and leave so i can move on and
label you the greatest of all time
because you can listen it's jose aldo
max hallway or volkanovsky is the the
best featherweights of all time
that's it there's those three can change
them in the prime whatever what whatever
order you want to put that in i'm fine
with it i don't care no argument here
but um volkanovsky
closed that chapter
boom
straight up outclass max hallway and he
commented uh on the post fight interview
that um in that second fight apparently
usada will come up like in the middle of
night like 3 a.m his team was like what
the [ __ ] right now he's sleeping he has
a fight tomorrow like this when we do it
so he did it he took a bunch of sleeping
pills like cbd sleeping pills so he's
like really groggy just out of it so he
said when we're in that fight he goes if
you can tell i just wasn't on i had an
off night had a really bad off night
volkanovsky and i died and make excuses
he's never told that story he said i
wanted to wait till i beat max holly
convincedly before i told that story
i believe him clearly because you can
tell in this this third fight this
rubber match fight he definitely got
better man and it's very evident they
will never fight again
so for alexander volkonovsky and max
holloway um
you know for volcanosky there are some
fights at 45 i would love to see but
obviously the big bucks for him is that
55.
55 is a bit of a [ __ ] show though so you
know we talk about 55 and volkanovsky
slow your roll because
there's currently no champion
um there's also a name
a man named islam makachev who has
deserved the title shot charles oliver
missed wait so he's not so there's no
champ so you're gonna have to have
charles oliveira and mokshev fight first
of all that's not even on paper we have
no plans for that so let's say that's
september maybe october
vote you tell me volkswagen early 2023
to fight like at lightweight i doubt it
i doubt it um you know and i like his
chance against charles oliveira i i'm
not crazy about him uh in his first
fight lightweight against islam not
crazy about that not crazy at all about
that
so you know i i'm curious if they do do
oliveira and makachev which i think
they're gonna do
um you know some point mid to late uh
2022. if islam wins that
does bokonasi still go up to 55
i don't know i think if charles oliveira
were to be there or they give him
charles oliveira over islam which would
be insane um i think he does it but i
think his team's going to wait a little
bit to see how islam looks against
charles
i think that's a much tougher fight for
him a very very tough fight for him but
there's some bangers at 55 but if you
want to go to 55 and you're the 45 champ
you want to do it for the belt right
you're not just going to do it to do it
i think if he does want a big name fight
and he doesn't want to go buy
kind of the normal protocols which the
hardcores like because the next fight
for him would be josh emmett correct
now
there hasn't really been a word spoken
about josh emmett and if you looked into
josh emmett's
uh i think tweets or something i was
reading the story the way the use of the
ufc flew him out there and uh basically
just treated him
they let you know what what they think
of you by the way when they fly out um
to some of these events you know
certain guys get certain treatment
certain guys they really take care of
certain guys they pay others they don't
pay certain guys get the sweet other
guys don't certain guys get walked into
the back and they get sat in the front
row and they get free drinks all night
and they get a [ __ ] per diem for the
outfit and all this other [ __ ] and then
certain guys like josh emmett who's the
number four uh guy in the world they go
hey here's nosebleed seats no security
with your wife have fun this is what we
think of you so emmett's like dude just
release me if this is what you think of
me [ __ ] let me out of here which is
such a shame man
um yeah no one's really talking about it
so this is uriah hall who can talk in
favor sorry this is uriah faber who can
talk like this because he's retired and
he's very close with the fertittas and
dana white so he says uh he's talking
about josh emmett here at ufc 276. he
said he had a really bad experience
um he was put way back in the seating
not even when the rest of the guys had
to find his way
by himself
upstairs because they have peons working
security that are getting paid minimum
wage are like hey you can't come this
way
he's not a confrontational guy unless
you're paying him to beat someone up he
was really upset that there wasn't more
made of the fact that he's the next guy
in line i'm gonna talk dan white about
it and talk to hunter campbell let them
know that this was [ __ ]
he goes emma got ghosted it's really sad
his wife was livid he was living just
like what do i have to do to get a
little bit of respect so dana i hope you
see this and understand that it's josh's
time
i would say this is an indicator the ufc
doesn't think it's his time
he's not even cage sign
if you're next in line they're going to
type that thing up and let's be honest
it's not like josh is ripping off promos
or talking [ __ ] that's not his thing he
lets his
he lets his abilities and and fights
speak for themselves and just has earned
his way to title shot
so to have him cage i can go this is
next would be great would build the
fight but
clearly ufc is not thinking that that
sucks for josh i've been there dude i
have been there
we've seen other people you know get
special treatment you're in the [ __ ]
way back you know nothing breaks your
heart more nothing makes you feel more
like a piece of [ __ ] you know it's like
it's like
riding the shuttle at an airport to get
to the rental car place nothing makes
you feel like more like a loser than
riding the shuttle with the rest of the
people and your bags are splashing
around and you're waiting on their all
[ __ ] day it's a nightmare dude
nightmare smells there's carpet
yeah you know
that's what it's like they put him on
the shuttle bus while everybody else was
in limos they put our boy josh emmett on
a shuttle bus to let him know that
they're taking him away from the title
shot that's what they did so if you're
josh it's a [ __ ] bummer
so if that's not next which clearly
isn't which is a bummer for josh sorry
josh um for volkanovsky you know i don't
know where henry cejudo is at
as far as with uh usada but that'd make
a lot of sense
if you want a big name fight put your
title on the line super fight you know
it won't be at 55 but at least it's a
big-ass name fight at 45
i could see them pulling that off if
they're going to play a game with cejudo
now cejudo interrupted sugar shawn's uh
interview which was hilarious
i think he might have been a little
drunk he was like i think you suck
absolutely suck i think you absolutely
suck see you're looking for a opponent
i'm looking for a warm-up but
i don't think sugar shawn wants those
problems not yet not yet i think
eventually you could beat him but not
right now
so i think for alexander volkowski henry
pseudo makes the most sense if he's
looking for a big fight
you know
but fun card overall
uh you know just gross clark got her arm
broke
uh macy barbour got a big win she's
looking for a title shot
so
[Music]
we'll see man
but overall good night of fights hope
you guys enjoyed the fight campaign it's
so fun to do next one is uh july 30th
for the next big pay-per-view i think
that's amanda nunes julian pena
but i'll tell you what's funny is the
ufc has a bunch of fights this uh month
in july these fight nights are pretty
lit
start with uh fazeev and uh dos anjos
this this saturday that's a fun one the
rest card's not great and now i say the
cards are good the the main events are
good so you got dos anjos fazeef you got
ufc london aspinall and uh
curtis coming up um what else you got
jen okay first one this is uh max
holloway
posting about
his fight with volkanovsky and it's
actually kind of funny so max always
goes i'm still up 2-0 on knockdowns for
the trilogy probably gonna need a fourth
to settle this laughing emoji just
playing congrats to my brother alexander
alexander volkanovsky go get that 55
strap you're in the shot you're the
number one pound-for-pound guy right now
is he number one over usman
argument there uh to all the fans do not
cry for me argentina this is part of
life we need to rebuild and we will i
love you
uh then alex said absolute legend
brother yeah i think for max he's done
at 45 i think he goes to 55. it's all
gonna be about styles there and
match-ups you know depending what they
want to do with them
and the next one is just um otasanya
some
reporter wanted to ask him a question
about jon jones and i'll just play it
for you
[Music]
well also have like the french
nail thing there yeah he does
huh hates his nails
he paints him but then he also has a
like a straight up nail job what do you
mean you know what i'm saying oh no no
so it's an illusion manicure it's an
illusion so he paints just the tips of
it so it looks like it's coming out like
it's longer
he can do it he was wearing pearl
necklace too or pearl necklaces
but basically he's like
john jones i don't talk about him
and let's come from gotta take some
fashion risk okay
[Music]
it was very gentle it's very jared leto
of izzy but listen when you're the
baddest middleweight on the planet dude
you could [ __ ] paint your face white
whatever you want to do go wipe face
dude don't give the [ __ ] be lit man
uh
france says since jones been sitting
back and talking [ __ ] izzy have defended
his style at least five times well done
champ some people talk some people act
hashtag three kings
nice consi him camaro and uh izzy are
the three kings because all from africa
right yeah
uh yeah i mean john just needs to fight
but the [ __ ] talk is hilarious
stephens going down though
yeah
all right what else you got buddy so
this was kind of weird a lot of fight
news going on yeah so dustin poirier
poirier and michael chandler probably
two of the nicest guys right in the ufc
they hate each other they somehow yeah
well they had an altercation here
[Music]
these from gilbert burns cell phone
[Applause]
you know what's interesting is the uh
it's yuri's just chilling um
what's interesting is uh
everyone says the same stuff about
chandler you're fake you're fake you're
not real everyone's the same you're fake
josh too right josh everyone yeah josh
the majority people interesting
i don't know what's going on though i
mean he seems as cool as hell to us yeah
he's always been great to me yeah i love
dustin too yeah it'll be a phenomenal
fight it's for pory it makes a lot of
sense i think for
for chandler you know he's probably
waiting for the
mcgregor fight if that doesn't work out
looking at the nate diaz fight you know
but pour a in a bad third option
no one has more choices than chandler
the ufc just has a pole trigger on one
of these big fish yeah he blew up so
fast here or here
at the ufc
we did help yep just kidding
he's done all the work there was a
little nothing i'm just kidding
uh okay so this is justin gage talking
about um getting no surgery he's been
waiting 13 years for someone to break
his nose after he first broke it but no
one's broken it so now he's gonna go to
the doctor and break it himself and then
get it fixed because he can't breathe
apparently it's been missed welcome to
the club dude
i can't breathe either daddy i'm doing
all right
i've broken wrestling back to 13 years
old life's been hell since then
i have to wear a nose
a nose drip to bed every single night
eating sleeping living training fighting
i'm not sure i don't even know what my
[ __ ] voice sounds like
i probably like mine dude it's not fun
i've been waiting for a long time to get
this broken one that's done so i'm gonna
do it myself give it one last run uh
towards the title yeah so he's out for a
hot second yeah
all right
during the uh was
pre-fight press conference israel sonia
said that he'd give three million bucks
to anyone who can give concrete proof
that he actually does steroids or knows
how to do steroids because of his you
know gyno yeah i don't think he's on
steroids you know the gyno and luke
rockhold alluded to it too during the
broadcast i i don't see it with him man
i don't you know i don't know what that
is but um
he says look i would give three million
dollars to anyone who could have
concrete evidence that i even know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing with steroids or how
to take steroids i promise you three
million if you find anyone who has
concrete evidence that i've ever even
purchased touch or done any kind of
performance enhancing drugs yeah i don't
think so yeah and this is the day that
he got his 50 clean test jacket
from usada or
uh let's go to
oh just real quick back to the pedro
munoz thing so he did suffer abrasions
to the cornea but then some guy did a
breakdown on youtube and it showed like
sean's punch right before
oh
right in the eye right now right now and
then later when he did the pokemon
combination of things but the pawn it
barely like rubs out that's what i'm
saying i looked at the pawn i was like
it's not like a jon jones like no no
knuckle deep balls deep in the eyes eyes
were closed yeah i just did this so i
mean i i think it's from the punch oh
well yeah
that's interesting yeah
that actually helps uh suga's case there
doesn't it yeah
but i mean there's no way to prove it
during the fight you know
oh
it would be erroneous for us to do a
show after donald cerrone
retires and first not to talk about it
you know cerrone price should retired a
few fights ago he talked about even in
the conor fight he didn't feel like
fighting so
um
you know cerrone's a straight-up legend
man i hope he goes on to make all the
movies i hope he's the next [ __ ]
clint eastwood i love donald cerrone
that guy has always been great to me
training partners for a number of years
when i didn't have money let me stay at
his house and train at jackson's when
he's living with leonard garcia just a
great freaking dude man legend legend
and he actually looked happy during the
time he said he wanted his head oh yeah
some people cry but he was just like i'd
be happy too if i had all those movie
offers i could get punched in the face
and go [ __ ] pretend to do this
any tips pratt
and this is hamzat calling out pahea
after the fight
really think of that fight
oh harms that sweet destroys them yeah
but still that's a good fight i'm
telling you the ufc ain't gonna do it
yeah that's the other thing here you see
toss uh your boy pierra to hamzad look
how that goes
eats them alive like my boy joey
chestnut with hot dogs
oh my goodness dude
hell yeah
well something's up with my computer but
what this is is daniel cormier at the
hall of fame speech
he actually admitted that he did cheat
by holding the towel yeah i'm sure like
there was a calculated
yeah good for him yeah shout out to dc
him and uh khabib got a
hall of fame hall of fame inductions big
deal man
all right
hopefully this works i mean can we get
the tough 10 cast hall of fame
season ever the biggest season ever
can we not get some jackets
should i send my sizes
are they going to let me in the building
am i the trail owns the ufc are they not
gonna have to make my own jacket
but even tito got inducted right and
dana and tito don't get along
yeah so it's possible yeah i don't have
tito's career
but still here yeah he's literally one
of the most famous guys to ever do it
but i like where your head's at jen
oh my god tommy fury uh i know
what's what's this
just go to the embassy
to get his visa that's all he has to do
but tommy is showing no urgency he
hasn't gone yet
he's not communicating with us on what
he's doing yeah look at his chain in
case of tommy fumbles just being scared
to fight me i think that's what it is i
think the fury family's trying to
manipulate something here to make me
fight in the uk okay you want me to
fight in the uk show me 15 million
dollars okay because here in america we
do more pay-per-view buys we do more
ticket sales and we do more sponsorship
i've shown you the money we're ready to
go msg august 6th
tommy you're gonna miss out on the
biggest payday of your life yeah it's
not happening is it because you want me
to come to the uk
like i said i'll come there just show me
the money but y'all can't do that y'all
don't have 15 million dollars
this is embarrassing go to the embassy
get your visa and let's make this fight
happen stop ducking me and stop wasting
my time
yeah jake is saying that he talked to
the lawyers through tommy fury's lawyers
and they said that all he has to do is
go to the embassy to get his visa and he
come into the country he still won't do
it you know what i apparently won't do
you just don't want the fight dude you
can totally do anything to make a fight
happen especially this bag yeah so it's
like you want to come to the england bar
so when jake paul goes you know us does
more pay-per-view sales well the
it's just a different kind of
business plan over in the uk
because you know when joshua fights or
fury fights it's different i actually
think their pay-per-view is cheaper so
they they
they sell more pay-per-views but don't
make as much that because america is
[ __ ] 80 bucks you know
tom is fishy out by wednesday morning if
he doesn't go to the embassy come out of
hiding through three other opponents
lined up i'm built different yeah that's
terrible dude
yeah um all right
the next one is just valerie lareda
which we kind of talked about before the
companion she's now she's done with
fighting and she joined the wwe
oh yeah yeah that's gonna be huge for
her
definitely she's a bona fide
dimer she's a dying piece yes good for
her but what
i don't know what it is man so i saw her
like clips of the interview with ariel
uh-huh there's something about it that
just i just
i just don't like really yeah i don't
think i've ever heard her talk
yeah but i'm a fan i'm a fan of you
sound like a hater i'm not a hater uh
let me see what let me see the interview
hold on this thing's just
your computer's dying is
is it too hot in here
that could be a tiny part of it but
so here's what she said
pretty much
i'd like to hear her say it though i
have now become the first cuban american
woman i am now a wwe superstar
i'm really excited i've dedicated my
whole life to martial arts and
everything has come to this moment this
opportunity to showcase my culture and
entertain the world i'm emotional
because i've worked really hard my whole
life i've had a very hard upbringing
every day i've always just believed in
myself trained hard hoping to make the
next step just chasing a dream that i've
had in my heart since i was a baby good
for her man definitely good for her
yeah there she is
jesus christ
but yeah i haven't had i mean dude top
five best league in all time man or what
i mean she's got to be freaking top
three top two top three yeah you might
might be number one let's be honest
her body everything yeah good for you uh
logan paul real quick just signed a
contract with wwe as well until 2023 i
think he signed all these people saying
hey don't look at the owner vince
mcmahon check out these new signings
yeah that's what they're doing that's
interesting yes
okay
let's see here
let's do a couple maybe one or two more
before your computer catch it i'm fine
this is a real quick point it's sounding
i know it was like making a farting
sound with
style bender
but this article is just i thought it
was interesting because um you know how
floyd mayweather jake's or not jake
logan said that floyd is not paying him
he's going to assume he's going to
worship his money hell yeah that's weird
right not the pay guy yeah and then
floyd's like you know how this business
works like
maybe not but it doesn't take a year to
pay somebody
so logan's insinuating that he just
doesn't have that much money but then
floyd put out this little message saying
that he pays 300 million dollars a month
just for the stuff that he needs to do
i mean yeah
i agree with logan i don't think he has
money dude hold on so just say yes no if
your nut is 300 million a month that
means you're sure he makes 300
3 million oh no i thought you were
saying his his
300 million that's what he's saying he
makes
a month mark
right 300 000. what are we doing
i mean how many billion dollars
uh
300 million that would be 1.6 billion a
month yeah i'm sorry a year 1.6 billion
a year
he says i don't know if i believe that
neither do i what if you're make yeah i
mean
i thought you were saying his nuts
through a millimeter i'm like yo he
definitely broke
ah
but yeah all right let's see what we can
do here oh here's the opening odds who
knows what floyd's doing with his money
he doesn't it's not good but also for
him not to pay logan is
definitely skeptical hippolyze it listen
maybe we don't know how boxing works but
i don't even [ __ ] what business you're
in even podcasting takes forever to get
your money off advertisers forever six
months three months sometimes i get paid
from 2019 and [ __ ] breeds i did it takes
a while you know because net 90 days
sometimes or net whatever
with boxing
even if it's net
180 days which would be insane he should
be paid by now
it's not good yeah yeah it's not it it
definitely caused some red flags with
floyd because if you have the money
you'd pay it right you don't want this
negative
people saying you're broke and all this
[ __ ] you don't need this yeah uh so
xpera holds two wins over middleweight
champion god how many times we're gonna
hear this [ __ ]
ah to sign you open up as a 180 favorite
against the plus 160 underdog for pierre
um but then
yet changed
numbers to minus 160 for adessanya plus
140 for pierre that line's going to move
right and the better is what they do is
they want to get your money so they're
going to make it really close so it
sways to get your money
a lot of people are betting on pr there
i'm surprised it's that close already
yeah oh me too yeah i think with izzy's
background what he's done in the ufc at
the high level i think is he should be a
minus 360. something around there yeah
nice 300 yeah it's insane it's
disrespectful
the
vegas and these bettors don't give a
[ __ ] about you know
izzy or
uh pierre they just want your money yeah
so that they're gonna align their so to
get your money moving they want to move
the line
is that it that's it man all right kids
boom there you go we got a lot going on
thick boy you got the new ufc 276 fight
companion available right now on youtube
you got the uh tim kenney food truck
available on fight or on a thick boy and
then we have a dope ass
food truck dropping for you with marvin
vittori coming up my favorite uh
i don't know if i'd say my favorite it's
definitely good it's definitely a rare
food truck this thing looks insane
it's pretty cool we have to bring
italian out for marvin victoria that was
the only request so we got a double
decker pizza food truck for him
um most expensive food truck in the
world so that's cool
um you got a fight night this saturday
yeah dos angelos versus fazeev they're
supposed to fight before phenomenal
fight i do think physique gets done
tougher fight than you'd expect though
joe sanjo's coming off two wins he's won
what three of his last five but he has
lost four as last seven so either way
it's a great fight at lightweight uh not
lightweight it's getting dicey dude you
don't have a champ right now you have
volcanos come jumping on over it's it's
a little messy up there so see what
happens it's a big fight with a lot of
uh implications on who's getting the
next title shot because eve is a [ __ ]
monster yeah other than that card ain't
great and i can lie to you
is that it that's it your boy is hitting
the road fresh off a uh
i'll say a three-day vacation in ojai
so i'm fully recharged i will be at the
laugh factory this weekend the improv
this week doing spots around town in la
but next week next thursday friday
saturday i'm in fort wayne indiana
fort wayne indiana never been looking
forward to it boys july 14th through the
16th is fort wayne indiana uh shauban
friends some monsters is july 20th
that's wednesday night 10 p.m show shop
and friends some [ __ ] monsters can't
wait for that the hollywood improv one
show only it's the late show because
it's so hot out i'm sick of doing the
early show because too hot so we changed
to the late show that's july 20th at the
hollywood improv shop and friends with
some monster friends and then san diego
one of my favorite places if i could do
my work either i would move there uh
tomorrow that's san diego california at
the laugh factory in the heart of
downtown san diego july 21st through
23rd special guest also is going to be
on there that's the laugh factory san
diego july 21st to 23rd
baltimore maryland is august 4th through
the 6th i've never been there
and then just
fresh off the press
chicago one show only at the den theater
august 26th that's a friday night this
will sell out it is one show only in the
heart of chicago downtown chicago den
theater chicago august 26 just announced
the reason i'm coming back to chicago
downtown is on the 27th i have a tough
mudder the thick mudder at 10 a.m you
can sign up the promo code is thick boy
you save 10 off on the sign up chicago
come on out um anybody else who wants to
come on out and run with the thick boy
squad i'm sure they'll have links up
there soon i will blast it all on my
social media come run with your boy at
10 am it's me versus uh the buttery bros
it's thick boy crew versus the buttery
bros is limited sign up they're limiting
the amount of people that can sign up
with your thick friend here because
getting out of hand i can't run with
everybody people get upset so they put
us in different flocks so they've
limited the amount of people that can
sign up to run with your boy
as soon as that link is live it will
blast on my social media
so you have the freaking thick mudder on
the 27th in chicago right outside
chicago on 26 one night one show only at
the den theater in downtown chicago get
you some tickets and then apple appleton
wisconsin september 8th through the 10th
houston boston's all on there get you
some but fort wayne indiana you're up
next and then is san diego tickets at
fakeboy.com or fatkz.com
it's the trash panda summer tour get you
some fort wayne europe stay thick
stay safe stay friendly love you guys
enjoy the fights
you